if you're building one of those off the  plan homes as an architect i'm going to  recommend one thing that my clients  complain about all the time  check your robe depths literally go into  your robe right now get out the  measuring tape and check it if your plan  has a rope depth that is smaller than  610 millimeters internal you are going  to struggle to fit a majority of your  clothes especially with wider coat  hangers it's very simple it's very  stupid but you wouldn't believe me how  many times clients walk into my office  and say make sure that this robe can fit  all my clothes because the last home i  had designed with a project home builder  ended up resulting in very very small  robes that i couldn't fit anything in